hey guys I know the question concerning
supplements and intermittent fasting okay what
do I recommend there's a couple things I'm going
to recommend probably one of the most important
minerals that you need when you're intermittent
fasting not just to prevent issues like with gout
or oxford stones but just because your metabolism
is changing from glucose metabolism over to fat
burning or ketosis metabolism you need a lot of
potassium okay so potassium is necessary and I
recommend the electrolyte powder simply because it
not only has potassium it has all electrolytes has
no maltodextrin it has a thousand milligrams
of potassium citrate which is really good to
prevent stones not just aqua stones but uric
acid stones that cause gout but it also keep
your energy up so you you're not deficient it's
also enhancement if you just can't get all the
vegetables okay so that's one thing and I take it
every day I put it in water drink it I might put
some lemon in there then I'll do it like twice a
day especially before a workout and it's just very
very hydrating especially if you're doing the
intermittent fasting in ketosis you're dumping
all this water you're losing electrolytes
sometimes too so you might just need to put
that back okay there's a tiny bit of sodium in
there like salt sea salt not much it's heavy on
the potassium and the other minerals and trace
minerals so that's one thing I recommend for the
B vitamins I would get a good nutritional yeast
that's unfortified okay make sure it's non-gmo
nutritionally you can do brewers yeast too but it's a
little bit bitter so nutritional yeast and that
way you can increase the B vitamins B vitamins
are necessary to prevent that fatigue or keto flu
or the feeling like feeling kind of heavy with
lactic acid like your legs are heavier so that
will actually because what happens is you burn fat
you generate a lot of acids so you want to be able
to take these to neutralize the acids and even if
you workout and you have a lot of lactic acid the
B vitamins will get rid of excess lactic acid and
other assets okay so that's what I recommend for
the B vitamins vitamins in general I basically do
the raw wheatgrass juice powder one teaspoon is
equivalent to a tray of wheatgrass it's just the
juice without the fiber you can take this when
you're fasting but it's kind of like a coffee
substitute it will wake you up it gives you all
the vitamins and minerals it has everything
in it so I don't take a multivitamin I take
that as my multivitamin so you can actually
take that just to make sure there's nothing
missing and then lastly this is like for people
that are really severely insulin resistant or a
diabetic or they just want to enhance the weight
loss because it actually has 10 ingredients to
support it's called insulin and glucose support
it supports the cells that make insulin it helps
to regulate normal insulin levels and blood
sugar levels okay so you that's another one
so anyway put your comments below and thank you
so much for watching hi guys thanks so much for
watching press this little button down here it
says subscribe and I will make sure that I won't
send more than five to ten videos a day okay
no I'm just kidding it'll be one or two thanks